let's now use what we know about the
chain rule in the product rule to take
the derivative of an even weirder
expression so we're going to take the
derivative we're going to take the
derivative of e to the cosine of x times
the cosine of e to the X so let's take
the derivative of this so we can view
this as the product of two functions so
the product rule tells us that this is
going to be the derivative with respect
to X of e to the cosine of X e to the
cosine of x times cosine times cosine of
e to the X plus plus the first function
just e to the cosine of X e to the
cosine of x times the derivative of the
second function times the derivative
with respect to X of cosine of e to the
X cosine of e to the X and so we just
need to figure out what these two
derivatives are and so you can imagine
the chain rule might be applicable here
so let me make it clear this we got from
the product rule product product rule
but then to evaluate each of these
derivatives we need to use the chain
rule so let's think about this a little
bit so the derivative let me copy and
paste this so I don't have to rewrite it
so copy and paste so let's think about
what the derivative of e to the cosine
of X is e to the cosine of X so we could
view our outer function is e to the
something as e to the something and the
derivative of e to the something with
respect to something is just going to be
e to that something so it's going to be
e to the cosine of X so let me do that
in that same blue color so it's going to
be e actually let me do that actually
let me do it in a new color let me do it
in magenta so the derivative of e to the
something with respect to something is
just e to the something it's just e to
the cosine of X and we have to multiply
that times the derivative of the
something with respect to X so what's
the derivative of cosine of X with
respect to X well that's just negative
sine of X so it's times negative sine of
X and so we figured out this first
derivative let me make it clear this
right over here is the derivative of e
to the cosine of X derivative of e to
the cosine of X with respect to with
respect to cosine of X and this right
over here this right over here is the
derivative of cosine of X with respect
with respect to X and we just took the
product of the two that's what the chain
rule tells us fair enough now let's
figure out this derivative out here so
we want to find the derivative with
respect to X of cosine eetu the X so
then once again let me copy and paste it
so we need to figure out this thing
right over here so first just like we
did we're just going to apply the chain
rule again we need to figure out the
derivative of cosine of something in
this case e to the X with respect to
that something so this is going to be
equal to derivative of cosine of
something with respect to that something
is equal to the negative sine of that
something negative sine of EDA of e to
the X once again we can view this as the
derivative of cosine of e to the X with
respect to with respect to e to the X
and then we multiply that times the
derivative of the something with respect
to X so let me do this in this I'm
running out of colors let me do this in
this green color so times the derivative
of e to the X with respect to X is just
e to the X so that right over there is
the derivative of e to the X with
respect with respect to X and so we're
essentially done we just have to
substitute what we found using the chain
rule back into our original expression
the derivative of this business up here
is going to be equal to let me just copy
and paste everything just to make
everything nice and nice and clean so
copy and paste so that is going to be
equal to is going to be equal to this
times cosine
X so this is going to be let's see we
could put the e to the X out front we
could put the negative out front so we
could write it as negative e to the
cosine X e so the cosine x times sine of
x times sine of x times cosine of e to
the x times cosine of e to the X so
that's this first term here plus plus e
to the cosine x times all of this stuff
and so let's see we could put the
negative out front again so let's put
that negative out front so we have a
negative negative
e to the cosine of x times e to the X so
I can write it this way e to the x times
e to the cosine X and you could simplify
that or combine it since you're
multiplying two things with the same
base but I'll just leave it like this
like this e to the x times e to the
cosine x times the sine we already have
the negative so then we have sine of e
to the X sine of e to the X so let me
write it over here times sine sine of e
to the X we had negative sine e to the x
times e to the X negative sine of e to
the x times e to the X and then that was
multiplied by e the cosine of X so we
have the exact same thing right over
here and we're done